without warning in the middle of the
night
myanmar's military made its move here an
mp
catches the moment soldiers arrive at
his house
pre-dawn raids the first confirmation
it was seizing power de facto leader and
chi along with the country's president
are among the officials detained
a coup in all but name as myanmar's
military
announces a state of emergency
the state of emergency is in effect
nationwide
and the duration of the state of
emergency is set to one year
this man commander-in-chief alflein is
now in control
he was previously sanctioned by the u.s
for alleged human rights abuses
against the rohingya the military
refused to rule out a coup last week as
it reiterated concerns over alleged
voter fraud
in november's election which ang sang
tsuchi's party won decisively
with a new parliament due to start today
it took action
today he was seen on state tv meeting
the man
now appointed acting president the
military refused to rule out a coup
last week as it reiterated concerns over
alleged voter fraud in november's
election
which and sang tsuchi's party won
decisively
with a new parliament due to start this
morning it took action
this is our worst nightmare come true uh
what we had was a
resounding election victory for the
national league for democracy
and the in the elections uh a clear
majority
a situation where democratic rule was
going to be entrenched
for another five years and overnight the
military just basically tore up the
rulebook
the few pictures coming out of the
country show people queuing at cash
points
in places phone lines and internet is
limited
with reports fear is growing people are
generally quiet right now and they are
whispering
and in the morning when i went out on
the weekend we have seen that there were
lots of nld
red flags out on the balconies but this
morning
i've seen people taking them down and
i've also observed that people were
trying to take out all the stickers of
nld
and all these uh triksha drivers
they no more are using nld flags
the military previously held these
streets for more than 20 years
before democratic elections in 2015.
today international condemnation has
been swift
these are rather disturbing
developments the details i've got to say
are very limited because of
communications that reportedly cut um
and it's still relatively early um
in myanmar in the past clashes between
the people and soldiers
have resulted in civilians blood being
spilled
this rogue move by the military has put
myanmar at a dangerous
and disturbing crossroads siobhan
robbins
sky news